June 26th 1998
pilot Trevor Wright is on a routine
flight over the hot red desert of the
Australian outback he looks down to see
a strange shape carved into the ground a
huge outline of a humanoid figure it's
over two and a half miles in Lane that's
gargantuan how did it get there there is
also the question of why why would
someone want to do this the strange bird
headed carving is located near the town
of Mari three hundred and sixty miles
north of Adelaide in South Australia the
figure is the largest depiction of a
human ever created it's even visible
from space for years the mystery remains
unexplained but then rumors surface of
an Australian artist called bar Deus
Goldberg who had a crazy idea to create
an artwork visible from space fattiest
Goldberg was by all accounts quite an
eccentric man who had talked to people
about creating such a figure he was a
person who drive to to create things
that got attention I understand that he
wanted to leave his mark on the earth
but a few years after the discovery of
Mari man the artist died in strange
circumstances at the age of 61 Goldberg
died in 2002 in as unusual circumstances
as I think he lived his life and got
caught up in a bar fight and had a tooth
knocked out and that led to septicemia
Nahid he died
Goldberg never publicly admitted to any
connection to the desert carving if he
had the solution to the mystery of the
Mari men bodies Gobber took that to his
grave in August 2016 locals decided to
restore the Mari man to its full glory
but to this day the original author of
the work remains a mystery
[Music]
you